yeah Lynn and I made this really tiny
movie called hump day about two years
ago and we really loved the process and
it was very similar to the DNA of this
film it was three characters it was only
a couple of locations it was made very
cheaply for like twelve thousand dollars
and we shot that film in like ten days
and it was just a great creative burst
for us so I called her and I said look I
have a similar kind of setup for a movie
that involves basically three people and
can take place on an island and I think
you know I loved working with you last
time let's do this again so I pitched
her this initial idea of a guy who's
recently lost his brother has a
friendship with a girl it's dubious she
sends him to her parents vacation
retreat on an island and there he runs
into her mother and and Lynn was like
okay that's good maybe the mother is a
little too mrs. Robinson maybe we could
do a sister instead and I said great and
so we we put it together and you know
these movies I guess they're designed to
be shot quickly and cheaply and they're
all improvised we work from an outline
but all the dialogue you see is actually
improvised and we shot the film in like
12 days we always wanted Emily Blunt for
it but everybody wants Emily Blunt for
their movies so the task is getting her
and she I think she agreed because she
loved hump day the movie we had made
together she was looking to be a
creative partner on a movie and to have
that creative authority to be able to
explore her character and exact her
character the way she wanted to and
again we shot the movie in under two
weeks so it was a small ask for her time
commitment and then initially we
actually built the movie with Rachel
vice as a sister and she had a
scheduling conflict and three days
before we started shooting we brought in
rose to save the day we have this this
soft preparation that happens for three
to five months before we make the movie
which is we all get on the phone and we
talked about the backstories for the
characters and we just create tons and
tons of backstory that we can draw from
during the improvisation we also talked
about see
ideas that we think could be good and
and and we imagined what the field the
movie is for me you know this movie was
all about trying to create something
with a classic melodramatic movie
structure almost like a soap opera if
you look at the plot points of this film
you know and but to try to do it in a
naturalistic way that felt organic and
and and and hopefully more realistic and
and so you know from there we we just we
create this rock solid outline that
tells us exactly what the story points
are so we always know we're going from A
to B to C to D in a certain scene but
how we get there is up to the actress in
the moment and I guess it's our belief
for for these very small very intimate
films that what we sacrifice in
preparation and planning you hope to
gain back in electricity and and that
moment when lightning can strike on set
because no one knows what's going to
happen you know but I really like this
form of film and I in many ways you know
not to get too you know serious about it
but I believe that this form of film is
the future of independent filmmaking and
we're seeing these lovely places like
fox searchlight and focus every now and
then a movie breaks out but most of
those movies are not doing well and and
this movie was made very cheaply for
that i would say relatively the cost of
you know one day's catering on a movie
like The Hunger Games and and I think
it's important that we were able to do
exactly what we wanted to do and explore
and and and that's the key component to
this film is we didn't have a great
movie in our pockets that we went out to
exact we had the seed of something that
might be okay that we went out to
explore and find and we were very
realistic we were just as capable of
failing as we were to find something and
and I think that you need that spirit of
being willing to try and fail to come up
with interesting things and it quite
frankly it's just hard to do you know
with a seven million dollar budget so I
like this form and I want to continue to
evolve it